welcome back to drew's news this year
marks the 20th anniversary of the
september 11th attacks and as we look
back and honor those who lost their
lives on that day there is one man from
boston who is on a very personal journey
in their honor his name is paulie venito
and he's a former united airlines flight
attendant who was off that morning
but lost members of his flight crew and
this year paulie is walking from boston
logan airport
where two of the planes that were
hijacked departed from to ground zero
pushing a beverage cart in honor of his
fellow heroes
he is 50 miles into his 220 mile trek so
we are very happy to speak with him
today where he is please welcome coming
to us from eastern connecticut paulie
veneto
hi polly
wow
hi paulie
how are you good to see you honored to
meet you you are doing such a beautiful
undertaking and
i would love for you to tell us about
why you are doing this
well um
because it's long overdue that we
let this country know in the world know
the horror works of those crew members
on that morning
they were they were never recognized as
the first first responders of 9 11.
they um they went hand-to-hand combat
that morning
and it's understandable why it was
overshadowed because of the enormity of
that day
but um
you know
it's long overdue that this country
recognized true american heroes those
flight attendants up there
they accomplish something that
is mind-boggling to me i get emotional
when i talk about it because every time
i get to this pot i start to feel like
i'm walking in their steps
of what they were thinking what they
were doing under those conditions it was
horrific
but we all know from the phone calls
that they made to the ground that they
were able to let us know where those
terrorists are seated in the midst of
that gruesome scene at eight o'clock in
the morning they had people you know
screaming for help or whatever was did
on the chaos they were still calm voices
and uh there were people just like every
one of us and um not trained to go hand
in hand combat
against terrorism but they did it all
the way to the end so as as a country of
americans we should
you know recognize them
to give their families a little peace
and uh i think of their kids their
nieces and nephews their cousins their
brothers their sisters have never heard
the words
i never heard it
i never heard anybody say
my relative was a flight attendant on 9
11.
and they were here
paulie i want to thank you for being
such an extraordinary
storyteller because the way you just
described
everything
humanizes it for us in a way that others
are not so eloquent
and
able to bring us into the moment of what
those people went through
it's the 20th anniversary of 9 11 and we
tend to look at the macro
but what you are doing is bringing us
into the micro in ways that i find
so compelling
so honoring
and so extraordinary
and i thank you for what you are doing
and i know it's also the sixth
anniversary
for something very big in your personal
life and i was wondering if you could
share that with us as well
absolutely um
after 9 11 i fell into an opiate
addiction
that lasted almost 15 years i flew for
10 years
numbing myself out on pain medication
and
i knew nothing about pain medication but
it almost took my life
um
i was told a long time ago don't quit
five minutes before the miracle
and um
i know that five days after 9 11 i knew
that these guys weren't going to be
recognized
and i i put a picture of these crew
members of 175 on my flight bag and i
brought that with me everywhere
as years went by and as my
addiction
became um
you know uh
you know you get deeper into it deeper
into it and um
i i was i was fueled every year by the
anniversary we come up and i and i
couldn't understand why nobody was
recognizing these people
and um
so in 2011 is when i pretty much crashed
and burned and um
i
i knew that through that time that dark
place i was in all i thought about is i
need to recognize these crew members but
i knew that i couldn't do that i didn't
know if i was going to survive what i
was in to do it i had to i had to
survive to recognize him so i just hung
on i just hung on i just hung on and i
didn't quit five minutes before the
miracle and the miracle was i finally
was able to put the stuff down and the
obsession was lifted it was a miracle
paulie i just see you sitting there on a
miracle shirt and i'm thinking about
your journey and how miraculous it has
been and i'm not talking about the
journey we're seeing now as you walk
across the country i'm talking about
your personal one but when i look at you
walking across the country pushing that
cart i think about how are you doing it
are you going from point a to point b
are you making stops along the way
well
i am um i'm doing it a step at a time a
day at a time a minute at a time
i go as long as my body will let me go
i've trained for this i get mentally
trained for it i've physically trained
for it so
um
i stay in a hotel every night um but i
you know whatever the weather is i i'm
prepared for it i just i do you know
there's a lot a lot my training has
changed a little bit since i started
because i i didn't have people coming
out of their houses and stopping and
pulling up and fire departments
you know and police departments and
everybody's stopping me it's and i'm so
grateful for that it's it's it's turned
into something i never expected the
awareness that you're raising
for this and also you're raising money
too for a non-profit called tuesday's
children in new york can you tell us
about that
well as
that all that part of it the raise and
money part of it is
i'm doing that to my best friend's
sister kelly wilson and and she's in
charge of the foundation which is hers
which is the
powerforward25.com which helps people in
recovery find sober living and grants in
tuesday's children which helps people
from the 911 foundations
and uh
so
they take care of all that stuff all i
care about is the rest of this country
saying you know something let's let the
everybody know let these family members
know that we recognize what they their
family member did that day as first
first responders we recognize that they
were heroes i want every one of those
family members relatives to hear this
from all of us i just i'm just the guy
pushing the card that's that's all it is
i want the rest of the country and the
rest of the world to spread this message
so that it'll reach these family members
or these crew members so their kids and
their nieces and their nephews can
finally say listen my aunt was a flight
attendant on united are american
and and they were a hero i want them to
hear that i think they will thanks to
you paulie and um
you have taken a very personal
journey
that you actually turned outward
and that's why kids are coming out with
signs and why we're talking here on the
show
and we're so honored that you've made a
pit stop with us we are one of many who
are cheering you on and we'd like to
donate five thousand dollars to your
journey
and to keep in recognition our hearts
are with all the brave people that we
lost in the attacks and thank you so
much for describing and bringing to
light their stories their humanity
and go to our website now to find out
how you can support paulie's push right
now paulie
thank you thank you paulie and go polly
go
we'll be right back
thank you paulie thank you so much